kirby in the forgotten land is the pink
puffball's biggest game yet it has more
moving parts to keep track of than its
predecessors and it also happens to be
the trickiest entry from a puzzle and
combat perspective while the forgotten
land is still fairly straightforward
there are some tricks of the trade we
picked up throughout our time with the
game and we've rounded up 10 tips and
tricks for kirby and the forgotten land
if you like this kind of video and want
to see more then consider subscribing to
gamespot
each level has a batch of waddle dees to
find a few are earned simply by beating
the level and every level outside of
boss stages has several hidden waddle
dees but each level also has three or
four other hidden objectives if you take
your time exploring each stage carefully
you should be able to uncover a secret
or two or perhaps even all of them in
one go complete the hidden objectives
and you'll free additional waddle dee's
if you don't find the secret objectives
though and some are really well hidden
so don't beat yourself up over it you
will have a better chance the next time
each time you complete a level one of
the mystery objectives will reveal
itself essentially this is a brief
statement that describes the objective
it can hint to a secret room or a poster
that needs to be knocked down or even a
group of ducks that needs to be reunited
with their mama once you have the clue
it should be easier to be on the lookout
the next time you play through the stage
kirby's copy ability has been his
signature move for decades so it's no
surprise that it's vitally important in
kirby in the forgotten land not only do
copy abilities help kirby in combat but
they are often required to solve puzzles
and levels to help find waddle dees
if there are enemies nearby that have a
specific ability drill fire tornado
cutter hammer there's a good chance a
puzzle or secret area that requires that
ability is around the corner if you're
going through entire levels with the
same ability chances are you're missing
some secrets
it's also worth noting that copy
abilities won't show up in the weapon
shop in waddle d-town until you use them
at least once so they're worth sucking
up for that reason too
kirby in the forgotten land revolves
around cool abilities that turn kirby
into a wrecking ball of force especially
when you upgrade those copy abilities
but it can be easy to forget that kirby
also has a built-in defense mechanism if
you're having trouble with a boss some
of the later ones can definitely be
tricky you're probably not playing
defense in spots where you could kirby's
guard ability can help mitigate damage
so watch your enemies moveset and put up
your guard the next time the brute tries
to hit you while the game doesn't
explicitly explain guarding you can use
any of the triggers or shoulder buttons
to guard so l zl r and zr and all of
them perform the same guard move you can
also move the control stick while
guarding to do a cool dodge move
[Music]
not long into the game you'll rescue
enough waddle dee's to have a house
built in waddle dee town this small
dome-shaped building is kind of plain
but it does serve a great purpose
kirby starts each level with the same
amount of health he had at the end of
the last so depending on how the
previous level went for you that could
mean trouble but you can take a trip
back to waddle d-town and rest in
kirby's bed to replenish your health bar
if you have any amiibo you can use them
to get in-game items in kirby in the
forgotten land amiibo not related to the
kirby franchise drops some coins and a
piece of fruit that replenishes health
if you do have kirby themed amiibo each
one does a different thing that could
prove to be helpful the boost and health
items you receive by scanning amiibo can
be used once and have a temporary effect
so scanning the kirby amiibo gives you a
life up which doubles your health as
well as star coins scanning the meta
knight amiibo gives you a speed boost as
well as start coins king dedede an
attack boost and coins and then waddle d
gives you a health potion and coins
nintendo recently reprinted the kirby
series kirby and meta knight amiibo as
well as the smash bros king dedede
amiibo for the release of this game so
some of the amiibo listed above should
be available in stores and online if
you're looking to try this out
you can also buy the previously
mentioned boost once the item shop opens
in the top right corner of waddle d-town
these boots can be very useful towards
the end of the game or if you're playing
co-op alongside someone who isn't very
familiar with action platformers
attack and speed boost can be stacked up
to five times plus you can hold the
sixth each boost lasts for 200 seconds
so if you add up all five it's a
thousand seconds
boost can be really helpful for the
coliseum which is essentially a boss
rush mode that can get pretty
challenging meanwhile health items can
be purchased at the wattle d cafe before
the item shop even opens
while the cafe serves several different
items we'd recommend sticking to the
maxim tomato since it only costs 100
coins and restores all of your health
you can carry one item or boost with you
at a time so it's helpful to always have
a maximum tomato on hand just in case
[Music]
often times before boss fights you get
to pick a copy ability to equip this is
the copy ability you'll be stuck with
for the whole battle so it's good to
stick with abilities you're used to but
if you have to choose between an evolved
ability and an ability that's still in
its standard state it's smart to go with
the evolved ability to deal more damage
if the copy ability you want to use
isn't available in that level you can
head to the weapon shop and equip your
favorite ability before entering the
boss level
some boss attack patterns don't gel with
the copy ability you're using in these
cases it doesn't hurt to drop the copy
ability and kill the boss the
old-fashioned way by sucking up and
shooting stars at them plus if you're
quick and you manage to inhale multiple
stars at once you can wind up doing more
damage than unevolved copy abilities
try to charge up your sword or hammer or
any of the copy abilities while fighting
a boss and look to see how much damage
you're doing you can do this by holding
b by default or y if you change your
controller settings there's a stark
difference between charged attacks and
regular hits this becomes even more
pronounced as you evolve your abilities
evolve forms or charge attacks can also
hinder enemy movement and give you even
more opportunities to deal damage i
found charge attacks of evolve fire and
ice abilities to be the most effective
seriously they are wild
[Applause]
[Music]
treasure road levels unlock as you
complete mainline missions
these time trials challenge you to use
one copy ability or mouthful mode as
efficiently as possible they are pretty
straightforward but here are a few
important details to know
first we recommend completing all of the
treasure road levels in a world before
moving on to the next world's mainline
missions this is because the rare stones
you acquire by completing them allow you
to evolve your copy abilities
second don't worry about the target time
of each level this secondary objective
only nets you a bonus of 50 coins so
there's not much of a point to try over
and over again to hit that time
especially when the target time tends to
require a near perfect run and lastly
explore the overworld carefully there
are a few points of interest usually
areas that look like something should be
there that prompt you to press a to
search the area some treasure road
levels are hidden and do not reveal
themselves until you unearth them this
way
and there you have it 10 things to get
you started in kirby and the forgotten
land
for more on kirby in the forgotten land
be sure to check out our review by
stephen petit both here on our youtube
channel as well as our website
gamespot.com we also have a written
version of this exact guide on our
website as well
and hey thank you so much for watching
for all things kirby and nintendo stay
tuned to gamespot
do
[Music]
you